the Joe Rogan experience yeah the UM I
think fate and circumstance are giant
the fortune is giant there's no question
about it some children get shot in
drive-bys you know that's just horrible
horrible luck and unfortunate
circumstance a lot of a lot of it is
fortune and fate how about people
getting lost right okay so the book that
I told her I wrote on the psychics
phenomenon what I believe about that
again I'm neutral right well not you're
not tell me I want to hear what you
believe hey there's a lot of people are
full [ __ ] absolutely God all people that
are talking about being psychic or full
[ __ ] but I do think that there is a
strange connection that we have with
each other that's intangible and I think
that some people have better connections
and others just like some people more
intelligent like we were talking before
the podcast about Elon Musk and it's
painfully aware when you talk to him
what a champ you are he's so [ __ ]
smart and his brain is it just it's
built different just like some people
have defective hearts some people have a
heart like Lance Armstrong it's
incredible huge of an anomaly some
people have giant hands he's a big heart
literally yes literally and they don't
know whether or not that's from training
or steroids and EPO and or whether or
not it's something he was born with they
really don't know but yeah as an
unusually sized heart it's usually large
but what was my point
they circumstance getting lost Oh
psychics psychics that's what is I don't
I think that most of the people that can
tell you the future a full ship most the
people that are tough I think people get
feelings I think sometimes you think
about someone they call you and I don't
know what that is I don't know if that's
just complete fortune like how many
times you think it about a person when
they don't call you that's the argument
against it but how many times you
thinking about that person they don't
call you but they're thinking about you
as well how many I mean how how often is
that with star-crossed lovers they find
each other years later and they tell
each other they've been thinking about
each other all the time and they can't
believe it
that's that's and when you get that text
from someone maybe that's just someone
prone to action but maybe there is some
sort of a connection some sort of
quantum
entanglement between you and someone you
spent time with or shared energy with
it's possible it's possible but the
problem is you have these mediums and
psychics and those people are just
[ __ ] and I have a friend
his name's banachek and he runs a Las
Vegas Mentalist show where he shows you
how he does these tricks but he'll tell
you absolutely these are trees been on
the podcast a brilliant brilliant man
but he'll tell you these are tricks I'm
showing you how I do this this I mean
I'm going to tell you that's a trek I'm
not going to give you the how I do it
but I'm gonna tell you while I'm doing
it this is a trick but he's pulling all
this information out of people about
their past their childhood he's guessing
people's ages he's guessing where they
grew up I mean and it's it's all a
little sneaky [ __ ] you know it's the way
they do it's it's a skill as much as
anything and so when you see these
people that are channelers or you know
psychics that are telling you about
someone in your past or trying to
contact you they're con artists almost
exclusively I mean then maybe there's
like one lady in Tibet that has a broken
gene and she could tune into the next
dimension and and pull some extract some
information from it but in my experience
the vast majority of those people that
I've talked to that claim to have
psychic ability were also at least
partially full [ __ ] they had weird ego
problems that were glaring that they
didn't notice you know like I could see
it that this is a gross way to behave
and they don't see it their
interpersonal relationships the way they
communicate with people was like an
agent like a fake Hollywood person or
something there's something bullshitty
about them yeah and people who lie a lot
I think if you lie a lot it's very
difficult for you to tell what a lie is
oh that's interesting yeah I think you
lose your connection I think when you
when you [ __ ] I think you also
[ __ ] yourself I don't think these
psychics are a hundred percent honest
even with themselves I don't think this
is like I'm gonna [ __ ] this lady over
she thinks you gotta talk to her husband
mo tell her some nonsense take her money
I think some of them actually believes
they're getting information you know my
grandmother used to believe that my
grandmother was a
she was a very eccentric lady and old
Sicilian lady and she would tell you
about the like old Italian ladies all
like want to play the lottery they all
have numbers there and she was playing
the numbers wasn't even the lottery it
was like the organized crime numbers
racket and she would always I was gonna
pick this number and I just add up the
last minute I changed the number
wouldn't you know it the first one came
in and she was so mad but it was always
that that I had a dream of this and I
had a vision of that and it was all
visions and dreams and psychics but
everything worked out horribly for her
it always did like if like you were
really psychic you would have better
instincts like this is just this
inclination that people have that
there's something special about their
perceptions and that their psychic and
it's always these really wacky people
that believe their psychics in my my
experience which I mean it's you're I
think you're talking also about that
what some scientists would call the
self-fulfilling prophecy you know that
if you believe this things happen
manifest themselves and you can convince
yourself that you believe this but for
me I'm super interested in people who
really believe in psychics right like
that's what and the military for example
and you know the most trusted Danes you
talk to those guys the remote-viewing
guys III talked to a lot of the
scientists who taught the remote viewing
and I talked to a number of remote
viewers and for the book but the most
interesting of all was the astronaut ed
Mitchell right and he was so so I'm
interested in like the psychology behind
what are you looking for in that and I
saw that I was doing some research in an
archive and I came across a photo of
what turned out to be ed Mitchell on the
moon reading a piece of paper okay it's
this extraordinary image because you're
like wait a minute he's on the moon and
he's reading a document what is that
document I found out the document was a
map of the moon okay Mitchell got lost
on the moon and literally pulled a map
out of like okay got I'm he was trying
to get to a certain crater and they had
a very limited amount of time there is
right there right okay there he is
Wow I mean think about that it's like
the most advanced technology of the time
why didn't the guy with the camera tell
him where to go hey bro this one that we
do good let's just follow our footprints
we're the only ones walking what are you
stupid
turn around look at the ground see those
things that's where you walked let's go
that way Jesus Christ I'd be so mad at
him I'm like bro you pulling out a map
who wrote that map
no-one's even been here come on man they
have little maps folded up in there in
their pockets in case they got lost they
were on the way to this crater and in
that crater they were gonna find
allegedly rocks that were gonna solve
the mystery of the moon's creation the
origin story is they'd like all this
pressure they couldn't find it the heart
rates up the guy's a huge Turner like
you got to turn back your heart rates
going crazy and think about it Mitchell
tells me I went to interview him at his
house when I think it was his last
interview before he died and he said
there we had gotten 240,000 miles - only
to get lost they missed the crater by
like you know 900 feet or something
really so he never got to the creek
never got to what he was devastated and
on the way back from the moon he has
this what he told me was a psychic
change right he his his consciousness
flipped and he became convinced that
psychic powers were real and that is
really the beginning of his foray I mean
Mitchell became a huge proponent of
psychic warfare of you know the the idea
behind what you're talking about that we
spoke of as being sort of charlatans ISM
and he dedicated the rest of his life to
it about aliens as well and I think that
we were definitely in contact with the
aliens and and that comes from like he
was so vilified by the scientists and by
the astronauts and by the kind of
military men because this was just he
told me the story of when they were in
quarantine after they came back from the
moon right he and Shepard were sitting
there you know eating breakfast waiting
and Shepard the story's a story broke
that Mitchell had done some ESP
experiments on the way back from the
moon
and Shepard said to him like look at
this nonsense the newspapers will do
anything to sell make a buck and
Mitchell said I I did that I actually
did that what experiments he was doing
ESP experiments on the way back from the
moon
he had a psychic in Chicago a Swedish
psychic that he was sending messages to
like she thought it was an old Swedish
man all right my psychic can take my
clothes off ya know I'll introduce you
to Olaf okay okay
I saw the movie frozen I didn't see that
one Olaf's the little snowman you got
younger kid anyway sorry so ed Mitchell
was talking to this hot chick in the hot
old man in and-and-and the story broke
because the the the Swedish psychic
could not resist telling you know
leaking to the press that he had done
these experiments what experiments will
do well psychics
trained on these little cards called
Zener cards right so like you have a
different symbols on them and you know
one one person that's how they decide
whether or not they're being psychic
like there would be a veil between us
and I would say what are you seeing
right and you would call it out so it's
like a control system and Mitchell had
these items with him on the way to the
moon and did these experiments to try to
see whether you could have a psychic
connection with someone back on earth
hmm I mean he that was you know did it
work well no and he took notes he showed
me the notes it was so wild to be at his
house in Florida and he pulls out this
old spiral notebook with like water
stains on it that actually went to the
moon hmm I was like wow this is really
something else I mean it was one of
those moments in time where you're just
like I don't know there was a feel there
was a feeling of sadness around all of
it mmm with Ed Mitchell sitting there in
his um you know his chair and talking to
me about what it was like to be an
Apollo astronaut on the walls I'm not
with a lot of these
horses with like incredible amounts of
awards on the walls but what does that
mean after time passes so his
experiments didn't work but he still
believed in psychic powers yes I mean
and that's and he okay's what we were
saying he was ridiculed you know and he
had such a tough time with it and so the
people who propped him up and the people
who gave him a lot of encouragement had
sort of more radical ideas as he grew
older and you know conspiracy theorists
who really kind of used him because he
was an Apollo astronaut so he was so
much more famous than any of them would
ever be and they really took advantage
of him I think so you think they
manipulated him with information and
tried to get him more and more
enthusiastic about their I mean it's
speculation on my part but you kind of
go where the love is right he was an
older guy and I seen some interviews
with him as he was getting older and
older and he seemed to be having some
difficulties thinking about things
clearly and people take advantage of
that yeah he was really obsessed with
extraterrestrial life who's really
interesting because didn't he claimed
that he had seen something while he was
up in space I think people helped him
make that claim that was my
understanding of it of reporting I mean
I stayed away from some of the crazier
speculative things about him because I
what I was really interested in when I
was writing that book was how his
authority and power allowed the program
to get funding right because so much of
this is it's like who's funding this
stuff and why and it really does come
down to Authority which is always a
which is always a narrative that I find
fascinating right how do people get the
authority to say go on these programs or
you know we should do that I mean the
question you asked of like how does
who's in charge right right and in all
of this what I learned more than
anything is that the office of the
president has a lot more power than I
think any of us are aware
[Applause]